we don't have a final declaration
of victory yet but the numbers tell us
it's clear
tell us a clear and convincing story
we're going to win this race
just look at what has happened since
yesterday
24 hours we were behind in georgia
now we're ahead and we're going to win
that state
24 hours ago we're behind in
pennsylvania
and we are going to win pennsylvania and
now we're ahead
but uh we're winning in arizona we're in
nevada
and in fact uh our league just doubled
in nevada
we're on track to over 300 electoral
votes
electoral college votes and look at the
national numbers
we're going to win this race with a
clear majority of the nation behind us
we've gotten over 74 million votes
let me repeat that 74 million votes
that's more than any presidential ticket
has ever gotten in the history of the
united states of america
and our vote total is still growing
we're beating donald trump by over 4
million votes
and that's a margin is still growing as
well one of the things i'm especially
proud of is how
well we've done across america and we're
going to be
the first democrat to win in arizona in
24 years
we're going to be the first democrat to
win georgia in 28 years
and we've rebuilt the blue wall in the
middle of the country that crumbled just
four years ago
pennsylvania michigan wisconsin
the heartland of this nation i know
watching these vote tallies on tv
moves very slow or slow and it's
as slow as it goes it can be numbing but
never forget the tallies aren't just
numbers
they represent votes and voters men and
women who exercise their fundamental
right
to have their voice heard and what's
becoming clear each hour
is that record number of americans of
all races
faiths religions chose change
over more of the same they've given us a
mandate for action
on covet the economy climate change
systemic racism they made it clear
they want the country to come together
not continue to pull apart
the people spoke more than 74 million
americans
and they spoke loudly for our ticket but
while we're waiting for the final
results
i want people to know we're not waiting
to get the work
done and start up start the the process
yesterday senator harris and i held
meetings with groups of experts on
public health
and economic and the economic crisis
this country is facing
then pandemic as you also know is
getting
more worrisome all across the country
daily cases are skyrocketing and it's
now believed that we could spike
see as many as 200 thousand cases in a
single day
the death toll is approaching 240 000
lives lost to this virus
that's 240 000
empty chairs kitchen tables and dining
room tables
all across america we'll never be able
to measure all that pain
and the loss the suffering that so many
families have experienced
we know something about what it feels to
like to lose to something
it feels like to lose someone i want
them to know they're not alone
our hearts break with you we want
everyone
everyone to know on day one we're going
to put our plan
to control this virus into action we
can't
save any of the lives lost any of those
have been lost but we can save a lot of
lives
in the months ahead senator harris and i
also
heard yesterday about how this recovery
is slowing
because of the failure to get the
pandemic under control
more than 20 million people are on
unemployment
millions are worried about making rent
and putting food in the table our
economic plan will put a focus on
a path to a strong recovery
look we both know tensions are high they
can be high
after a tough election one like we've
had
but we need to remember we have to
remain calm
patient let the process work out
as we count all the votes you know we're
proving again
what we proved for 244 years in this
country
democracy works your vote
will be counted i don't care how hard
people try to stop it
i will not let it happen the people will
be heard
our journey is toward a more perfect
union and it keeps moving on
in america we hold strong views
we have strong disagreements and that's
okay
strongest strong disagreements are
inevitable under democracy
and strong disagreements are healthy
they're a sign of a vigorous debate of
deeply held views
but we have to remember the purpose of
our politics is in total
unrelenting unending warfare
no the purpose of our politics
the work of the nation isn't to fan the
flames of conflict
but to solve problems to guarantee
justice
to give everybody a fair shot and to
improve the lives of our people
we may be opponents but we're not
enemies
we're americans no matter who you voted
for
i'm certain of one thing the vast
majority
of 150 amer 150 million americans have
voted
they want to get the vitriol out of our
politics
we're certainly not going to agree on a
lot of issues but at least we can agree
to be civil with one another we have to
put the anger
and the demonization behind us it's time
for us to come together as a nation to
heal
it's not going to be easy we have to try
my responsibility as president we will
be to represent the whole nation
and i want you to know that our work is
hard for those who voted against me
as those who voted for me that's the job
that's the job it's called the duty of
care
for all americans we have serious
problems to deal with
from covet to the economy to racial
justice and climate change
we don't have any more time to waste on
partisan warfare
you know and more than that we have such
an incredible opportunity to build the
future
we want for our kids and our grandkids
i've said many many times i've never
been more optimistic about the future of
this nation there is
no reason we can't own the 21st century
we just need to remember who we are this
is the united states of america
there's never been anything anything
we've been
unable to do unable to accomplish when
we've done it together
i hope to be talking to you tomorrow i
want to thank you all
and may god bless you and may god
protect our troops
good night